Amber Heard getting some rare support
from a famous friend amid her ex-husband
Johnny Depp's ongoing defamation lawsuit
against her actor David krumholz
speaking out on Instagram
the actor and heard co-starred in the TV
drama at the Playboy club in 2011 and
now he's reacting to negative portrayals
of her amid the trial I didn't even care
anymore at this moment I was he had
already ripped my heart out krumholtz
shares these messages to insta story
kicking things off by writing
controversial opinion he then refers to
heard as a victim of abuse by Johnny
Depp following up with drugs and alcohol
turned men into monsters I believe Amber
Heard it's a rage when he started to
pass out a lot and fall asleep as part
of her testimony in the ongoing trial
Hurd alleges Depp suffers from severe
addiction issues which Depp has denied
the characterization of my substance
abuse by his herd is grossly embellished
crumboldt goes on to say while herd may
not be innocent she is a victim adding
Johnny Depp's smugness during the trial
is sickening he finishes his thought
with this I worked with Amber Heard she
is not psychotic she is brilliant and
strong and got caught up in both she
made a mistake why is Johnny suing her
because he has not owned up to his
raging addiction issues Johnny Depp is
the one who filed this lawsuit he wanted
the public to love him again and by the
way if you look online at the online
support it seems to be working the
trials become a bit of a circus
inspiring controversial parodies like
this one from Saturday Night Live
Mr death are you finding this trial
amusing
a little
so am I get back Captain Jack
and Days Later Lance Bass shares this to
tick tock lip dubbing audio of herd's
testimony I was just sitting there on
this on on this carpet looking at the
dirty car
s on this carpet looking at the dirty
carpet wondering how I wound up on this
carpet but amid several domestic abuse
claims grab me by the hair swung me
around critics are saying any attempt to
poke fun at the trial is in bad taste
the tip of my finger
had been
severed while on one hand I've never
seen a case quite like this before as
legal expert Jesse Weber tells E.T the
media attention adds a new layer to the
already complex legal battle the
celebrity Factor here particularly the
fan base for Johnny Depp is so unique so
it's going to be kind of tough to judge
other abuse cases that have happened or
might happen based on this one but
having said that I am concerned at how
Cavalier Society has been a dismissing
Amber heard's allegations it's
disturbing and yes it's going to give
maybe people in the future pause before
they come forward with allegations
against an A-list celebrity I mean
ironically this was the very thing that
Amber Heard warned about in her
Washington Post article the article that
Johnny Depp is suing about that she came
forward in society and culture went
against her
foreign